it's not really relevant to the video
actually but this is a slow loss I just
thought I'd show it because it was cute
that's all don't keep them as pets
though now your slow loris is I guess my
favorite denial-of-service attack now
that says a lot about me doesn't it that
I have a set of favorite deny the
service attack before I demonstrate
anything of course it gets fat in the
open you shouldn't be using slow losses
on anyone or any other denial of service
attack on anyone else right because
you're getting a lot of trouble
most another service is the idea that
you try and defeat some web server or
some computer on the other side of the
web by giving it as much bandwidth as
you can such that it breaks right they
have a certain amount of bandwidth
they're allowed to use and if you give
them more than that or try and request
too many web pages their server goes
down that's a general idea of denial of
service distributed denial of service is
just the next level where you have
multiple computers all the tempting to
do the same thing and then more modern
denial of service will use amplification
and things like this to try and improve
this even more but the whole point is as
much bandwidth as you can all at the
same time right and if you get enough
you can take them down if you don't then
they just laugh right so you know
Microsoft and Google you're gonna have
gonna have difficulty bringing them down
but smaller websites it can have a
massive impact on the amount of money
they're making if no one can visit their
shop or something like that
so it's a real problem what I like about
the slow Louis is it comes at it from a
completely different way it's a protocol
attack so a layer 7 application attack
which doesn't need a lot of bandwidth so
I can do a slow Louis on someone and
then just browse the web as normal play
computer games so let's think back to
how me talking to a web server works I
send off a get request to a web site and
I say get me index.html then the web
server sends back index dot HTML and
that's the end of that conversation
right then I start off another
conversation it says I've read this
index.html
I now need you know header dot jpg so I
send off another get request and so on
and we have these short conversations
back and forth now usually an HTTP
request is just text right so it
literally says HTTP GET 1.1 or something
index.html where I'm sending it a bit
about me so I'm using you know Firefox
or something and then some other data
it always ends with two carriage return
line feeds so two new lines right so
normally in text we have a carriage
return character and then a line feed
character two of those signals the end
of an HTTP request what the inventor to
slow Louis some hacker named our snake I
think decided was what if I never send
those carriage return line feeds can I
just keep the website waiting for me can
I go so slowly by asking for websites so
slowly that I just break them and yeah
you can and and so they have things like
timeouts and stuff so maybe let's say
I'm in the middle of browsing a website
and then on my phone right and just as
I'm in the middle of sending off a
request I lose phone signal right that's
pretty common in you know these days so
that would timeout on the server's end
as well and they would let the
connection go and then they can serve
someone else a website the problem comes
if I don't send no data I send some data
but just painfully slowly well it's
great about the slow lorises there's
hardly any code it talks to a web server
and it basically says get me index.html
or something like that and then sends a
space or a zero or random number or
something like that and then it waits
for about you know 10 20 30 seconds just
when the web site is about to assume
it's gone and sends another single byte
and says I'm still here I'm just really
slow and then it does this again and it
does this again and keep that connection
going as long as it can and when it does
it with 200 other connections or as many
connections as it can so my computer
sending it out this attack is sending
200 byte packets every minute or so it's
not a lot at all and it's very difficult
for a firewall or something to notice
this because these are valid HTTP
requests they're just super slow alright
and you know maybe I've just got a
really bad internet connection maybe
yeah
now this doesn't affect every web server
it mostly affects Apache because of the
way Apache works unfortunately patch is
very prevalent there's about a 40 50 %
Apache these days it's hard to know for
sure but I had a quick check and that
seems to be about the rough estimate
they go up and down
Apache when they designed it they
decided it would be a good idea
to start up a new thread just to serve
every concurrent connection so when a
connection comes in with an HTTP request
they set up a new thread that handles
that request and then the thread goes
away when it's finished now that wasn't
entirely stupid you know if the
connections appear and then they go away
that's not a problem but if the
connections start to stay open longer
than we anticipate then our connection
limit gets reached so if perhaps you
will have a connection limit of let's
say 200 concurrent connections because
beyond that you've just got so many
threads the whole thing starts to grind
to a halt so what slowloris does is
begin to open connections and as a new
one gets freed up from someone else
using the website they'll open that one
and they'll open this one and they'll
open this one until they got all the
connections so let's see how it works
right so I I've come up with enough of
my glorious websites just for this
mike's website so that's actually this
computer here which is running Windows
in Apache now so this is my website with
my company profile in long Epson what
this website is not very important let's
have a quick look at the code this is
not the original implementation of slow
Louis this is a Python implementation I
found but essentially it's not very long
right 67 lines which is another reason I
like it it's so elegant really what it
does it has some code here to start up a
socket which is a TCP connection and
make a get request here's I'll get
requests text and then for all existing
sockets down here can we send a little
bit more data every 15 seconds in if a
socket dies we recreate it and we just
keep that going and it will do this for
200 concurrent sockets which is more
than my Apache installation is
configured to handle so let's run this
then we are - slow Louis to the IP
address that we just looked at
right it's created all the sockets and
now it's just going to sit there every
now and again sending a byte of data to
this Apache web server so the web server
thinks that it's got 200 people looking
at the website when in fact it's got one
person looking at the website really
really slowly 200 times if I press
refresh on this because it's been cached
we can see we're now waiting waiting so
if you clear the cache now on your
browser with that know I'm going to see
the website so let's go to website now
that we're under slow Louis so right we
wait
I mean we might get lucky maybe one of
these sockets drops out and then the
server can respond right but we might
not but yeah at some point we might see
a timeout on this client side saying I
didn't get any response to the server
this server has basically won't serve
this website to me because it's too busy
serving 200 other websites or more
specifically busy waiting for us to
finish the request 200 time so it can
actually finally get on with something
as long as I want and as soon as the
socket dies another one comes up and
just keep going I meet 67 lines of code
right and and here's a nice bit fun
things to do I can just use the net as
normal my net is fine right I'm not
using all my bandwidth to do this I'm
using barely any of my bandwidth which
is what I really like about it this kind
of attack is called a low and slow
attack so there's a couple of others
Rudy are you dead yet is another one
that does similar things and what's
clever about them is they're quite hard
to detect because what it's doing is
totally normal HTTP it's just doing it
incredibly slowly and when they peep
when they designed this and when they've
designed a patch of it no one ever
thought you'd do something like that and
that's exactly the problem with these
sort of protocol attacks the assumption
that they'll always do what you expect
them to do and they won't do these
random strange side things so yet my
favorite denial service
if you rename a document you don't
change the document so if I rename the
file not empty txt to be still not empty
dot txt but the key thing is that every
time you create an atom for the same
string are the same sequence of
characters you get the same atom back